Let's now dive in and understand how to use this cryptic name maximum likelihood estimator.
The reason is because the estimation problem is given data, find the probability p
which now a simple example was the probability of heads.
Given a fixed p we started in probability, what's the probability of the data.
So let's begin with the second and find a good solution for the first problem--
the estimation problem, and again I'm going to ask you a quiz.
Supposed my data looks like this--I want you now for the different values
of p to calculate for me what's the probability of the data.
Remember this is exactly the problem we discussed earlier when
we introduced probabilities of multiple independent events.